well call of duty black ops cold war
season 2 landed a little early for some
you can play outbreak mode offline
here's some early gameplay showing how
escort and high value target missions
work
keep in mind we can only play solo but
normally this would be done with up to 4
players
to see tons more call of duty videos
make sure to give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel
let's get to it
[Music]
make sure the rover crosses the
dimensional threshold any intel it
recovers will be key to our
understanding how the dark ether affects
organic matter
detected
stop here yeah
scanning structural stability of anomaly
[Music]
anomaly non-viable continuing standard
scanning procedures
i would never refuse this
return to rover to reasonable escort
good morning
her dropped
adjusting vector to match breach
return to rover to resume escort
beginning approach scanning for stable
dimensional conduits
anomaly non-viable continuing standard
scanning procedures
[Applause]
so
no coming back from that
required
there's our breach get through it and we
should be golden
one last push we can finish this
foreign
there you go
payload is in the dark ether thanks for
the escort
hmm
[Music]
weaver our disruptor satellite has good
alignment ready to breach
ascending coordinates to the uplink
terminal get the dimensional disruptor
operational
using pure ethereum the dimensional
disrupter breaches the dark ether
and forces an apex hvt into our world
you're the killer on site strike team
only picks targets a priority one
[Applause]
about time you dropped
[Applause]
hmm
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
post mortem hostile down
initiating firing sequence
firing in three two
one
good breech good breech apex tethered
barry the son of a [ __ ] it's got
reinforcements
eyes on target
get back to it i want that threat
eliminated
black
[Music]
foreign
huh
it's moving follow that energy trail
target reacquired southeast of your
position
you